we have Sophia Vergara we we covered
last week she's getting a divorce so
this woman is 51 and twice divorced
she's been ensnared in a legal battle
with another ex-boyfriend that she never
married because she wanted to destroy
the Frozen embryos they'd created via
IVF and he didn't her most recent
divorce is allegedly because her ex
wanted kids and she didn't but hey she's
partying in Italy in a swimsuit this is
exemplary of what is wrong with Western
Society there's no shame in being single
well the very few people are being
called to a lifetime lifetime of
singlehood no one is called to a series
of broken marriages single doesn't look
so great when you're 70 and alone it's
really interesting because it's almost
like we live in like a fake world
because these women like they get their
faces Frozen and like they get all these
like natural stuff where they don't look
their age